[inaudible] so what do
you make of what's the,
the onslaught against Christians?
Because I talk about it,
I talk about it pretty frequently on, on
Twitter and here, and I'm not Christian,
but I see what's going on. And this is
now the state sanctioned bigotry. Yeah.
That's okay. Not quite
state, but like, yeah.
If you care about what the
media is allowed, you know,
you can always attack white Christian
man and they're all homophobes in,
they're all big gates and
all of this nonsense. Yeah.
And I go to events with these people all
the time and I find them to be decent
and respectful and willing to disagree
and walk away without punching you.
Yeah. And everything else. But what
do you make of just like the focus?
Yeah. On that. Well, it's part of,
it's part of intersectionality.
You posted the quiz the
other day that it was like,
what's your intersectionality score?
Intersectionality scores.
And one of the things that you could
slide was whether or not you're a devout
Christian. The more devout
of a Christian, you are,
I guess the more privileged Dui or the
lower you are in the intersectionality
scale or something like that.
And so I think it's just associated
because America and the West, uh,
why is driven by,
uh,
by Christianity and what's driven
specifically by Protestants.
I mean the revolutionary war was seen
as a Presbyterian rebellion and a lot of
those people line anything with anything
that is aligned with Americanism is
white nationalist is wrong, is imperialist
Christianity gets tied up in that.
Now for Evangelical Christians,
we also know because the Bible tells us
that the Church of Christ is going to be
pushed to the margins and tell
the world comes to an end.
And so we will be persecuted, we will, uh,
be more and more marginalized am yes,
we can continue to fight
for Christian values.
We continue to fight for being left alone
really is what we're really fighting
for.
Just kind of leave us alone.
That's what Protestants pretty much
have always done. Um, but yeah,
I mean at the,
at the end of the day,
we know that it's not going
to end well for us probably.
Yeah. It's really crappy
situation. Like every day,
just another tweet and another
story, this nonsense, you know,
they'll do Chris Pratt church and
they'll try to make it seem like, oh,
he's a homophobe and he goes, he's
homophobic church and it's like, guys,
you want to do a lot Omar's mosque,
now you want to do that.
But they don't want to do that because
actually they're the bigots. Right.
That really is the truth.
Yeah. And that's the thing is that
they're fine. They're really fine.
The left is fine with
you being a Christian,
as long as you don't actually
believe what the Bible says.
So as long as you believe the
staff about feeding the poor,
as long as you believe that kind of stuff.
But that has to mean the government,
they got rid of it, feeding the floor.
You have to do it their way. Right, right.
Is longer. You're down with that, but
you have to take away the wrath of God.
You had to take away
Jesus be the only way,
truth and life you have to take
away the biblical marriage stuff.
You have to take away the abortion
stuff if to take away the hard work that
proverbs talks about that even the
apostle Paul talks about kind of take all
that away.
As long as you're the Christian that
believes in well three distribution.
You're good.
Yeah. Huh. All right. So let's dive
into some of the topics of the day.
You mentioned the uh, the wage
gap. Yeah, it was recently. It was,
what was the gender
pay gap day or Hashtag e you're saying
she don't even let her know our day,
even though I just made sure to pay
all my female plays less that day. Oh,
just really drive it home. Yeah.
Is it a myth? What's going on here?
It's a myth because,
well, it's partly a math.
What they don't tell you is the entire
story is this whole uncontrolled gap
through our versus the controlled gap.
And actually heard about this
originally on a more left leaning site.
That's an organization up in
Seattle that fights for equal pay.
And they actually taught me on their site
the difference between an uncontrolled
gap and a controlled gap.
The encore
toward a great Twitter
thread on this by the way,
which we'll link to in the description.
Yeah,
yeah.
It was the control the gap account or
I'll start with the uncontrolled gap,
does not account for job title,
doesn't account for experience
as an account for hours work.
It really doesn't put any factors
in. It's just the median, uh,
what women make versus the median, what
men make, which is 79 cents to a dollar.
That is true,
but it doesn't account for any choices
or an experience that controlled gap
accounts for all of those things.
So it accounts for job title hours worked,
all of that. It doesn't account for, uh,
like negotiating a raised as an account
for end of year bonuses or anything like
that.
But it does account for the big factors
and that is 99 cents on the dollar.
So women make 99 cents to every
dollar that a man makes. But again,
you're not accounting
for a few factors there.
And that could be within the
margin of error. So no matter what,
there is no proof that there is
systemic sexism that is causing women,
uh,
to make less money.
Well, it also doesn't account for the
fact that men and women choose different
careers. Yeah. At the
most simple level. I mean,
the best example of this is Sweden
where they have been, you know,
completely egalitarian for ever basically,
I guess what,
there is still more male engineers and
there's still more female versus, yeah.
So now they want to like force people to
do things that they don't actually want
to do so they can get it 50 50 which yeah,
that's really how freedom work.
No. And there's, I mean,
there's a million different programs
to try to get women into stem because
they've said for so long that the reason
why there are so many more men in stem
is because women feel intimidated and
because there's this patriarchal attitude
in the stem field,
while so they've tried so hard,
they put so much money
behind it and still,
I mean men are outpacing women or there
are so many more men in stem that,
I mean just as many as there's ever been.
And so it's probably
not 80 outside factor.
It's probably because women
in general are different.
How much of this do you think is
just misguided sort of confusion.
So for example, you're pregnant now,
your husband's here in the green room,
your career is there going to be a little
bit different because if you're going
to probably take some time
off to child rear, yeah.
Maybe he will take some maternity
time. Maybe not. But yeah,
just physiologically we just
are different. They don't
like talking about that.
Yeah. Um, but that is just
the nature of reality.
I saw a study the other day that it was
like breaking news and it was some study
out of the UK that showed that there
is a difference between boys and girls
brains inside the womb. That
is, uh, is it early as you know,
however many weeks gestation that a
child's brain is developing and they start
going in these divergent paths
of women. Um, the, just the,
how the neurons connected,
women kind of being grown into
these interpersonal creatures,
whereas men are more focused in
general on objects and data and things.
Women are more focused on ideas and
words and people that starts in the womb.
And I'm like,
I'm so glad science is finally catching
up to God and finally catching up to the
things that we've known
for thousands of years.
And so you do wonder if that's
going to happen, if, okay,
we're trying all of these cool social
experiments right now. Like maybe, oh,
maybe it'll be fine if we draft women.
Like maybe it'll be fine if we just
pretend we just are totally gender neutral
with our kids and pretend like no
binary definition of gender exists. Um,
but I do wonder if science will
catch up with us and be like,
actually all these things
that conservatives were
saying that the left dot,
we're social constructs,
they're just biological reality.
Well,
they also made find out what if they found
out that there was a gay gene one day?
Yeah. Now they're pro choice, would you,
you have to be okay then with a
woman deciding to abort that baby
because they don't want
the child to be gay.
And that does put them in this
kind of ethical conundrum. I mean,
but it's the same thing with,
with race.
I mean I guess you would know what race
your child is obviously before you had
an ultrasound or anything
like that. But uh, you have,
I mean there is a racial
aspect to abortion and that
the majority of abortions
happen in minority communities. And so
when you ask a pro choice or about that,
they don't typically have
any kind of answer though.
All right. Wage gap. Uh,
you briefly mentioned the trans
situation or gender roles. Yeah.
The trends issue for considering it's,
you know,
0.01% of the population or something.
And I have complete sympathy. Yeah. Uh,
with the issues that they're dealing
with a little overblown in our national
discussion.
Yes.
And I think that the left does that a lot.
Maybe I'm going to give them the benefit
of the doubt maybe with good intentions
because people with gender dysphoria,
it truly is a struggle.
I know someone with gender dysphoria and
it is a struggle. They didn't want this.
They didn't,
they don't like this kind of struggle of
feeling like they don't belong in their
own body. It really is a psychological
struggle, but you treat it as a struggle.
You treat it as something that,
okay,
we don't just say while live what you
want to live because they actually,
the rates of suicide are pretty
much equal afterwards. Um,
it doesn't actually reconcile
anything when we say, okay,
just do what you want to do because it
truly is a disorder in a dysphoria. Um,
and I think maybe in an attempt to be
compassionate to the people that are
dealing with this and to help them
not feel ashamed that left to said,
you know what?
We're just going to who you are.
I personally don't think
that's the compassionate thing
to do, to lie to someone.
And I know a lot of conservatives
feel the same way. Um,
but then you do start finding yourself
getting angry and defensive about a
subject that we should have a lot of
sympathy for because people force you to
use gender pronouns that
you don't want to use a,
they force you to have conversations
that you don't want to have.
And that's where things just get really
sticky. And that's when unfortunately,
conservatives,
including me,
we get really dogmatic about it and the
sympathy and compassion is thrown out
the window.
Yeah.
So what do you do to fight that?
Cause that I get that it's tough if you
just keep being called to transfer over
or any of these phobes well
eventually you're just like,
all right then enough of this,
I'm gonna go for the destroys tweet
and scatter of the compassion tweet.
Well the tweets are difficult
because the tweets, it's like
you only have so many
characters and putting out the
nuanced compassionate tweet
is typically not what comes to mind. I
think when you're just trying to put your,
put your idea out there, you don't have
time to add. The new ones are like,
I'm just going to get to the
point I want to say that's right.
But that's typically my tendency and
our tendency and I don't think that's a
good thing.
But in conversations I always think it's
really important to define your terms.
If you have a same leftist who was
saying you're a trans phobe. Okay,
well we need to define phobia and we
need to define what I believe in what you
believe and maybe we actually
agree on a lot of the same things.
We just disagree on the facts.
We just disagree on the variables.
So I think defining
the terms is important.
It starting with what you
agree is important. Uh, and
then working out from there.
How often do we do that?
Maybe not enough.
So would you, do you think it's fair to
say that the average conservative, well,
first off, you know, the, when they
keep putting fold at the end of a word,
phobe is an irrational fear.
So I assume you don't think
that the average conservative
has an irrational fear
of trans people?
No,
I don't think so.
Okay. So what, what do you think the
average, do you think the average PR, uh,
conservative has the thoughts
that you laid out earlier,
which is sort of a sympathy for this,
but then we don't want that
to override or thinking brain,
something like that. I think some
people are saying you don't want,
I really don't care if you dress like a
girl or you dress like a guy or you want
to call yourself something.
Um,
I just don't want you to force that on me.
I don't want you to take away,
for example, my religious liberty
in lieu of like I, I, I don't know,
they don't want their rights trampled
upon in favor of this small group.
Uh,
however,
I do think there are people that kind of
see where this line of reasoning goes,
that if, okay, we deny
biological realities, we deny
what science is telling us,
and we buy into this delusion that a man
can just wake up one day and say that
he is a woman, then okay, we kind
of lose, we kind of lose all truth.
What is truth anymore? It's just
what you feel. We lose identity.
It's just who you say you are.
Or are you actually defined
in any way by biology?
And I think they see the kind of slippery
slope did that goes down and they say,
okay, stop right there. I'm
not down with this. Okay. And
it all sounds crazy to just wake up
and you know, middle age and be like,
well now I'm a female. But it's
like at that point, I mean this is,
this sounds bananas,
but if you were a washed
up male NBA player couldn't
play in the league anymore.
You can be like, yeah, I'm a woman
today. I identify as woman, right? Yeah,
I'm jumping in then WMV and I'm
going to be the MVP, watch this.
And then the feminist would have to say,
yeah, your lived experience. Yeah.
Well that's the other problem with
it is that you're kind of seeing some
feminists pushback on this
and say, hang on. Well,
old school feminists have
been kind of saying, okay,
we fought for the uniqueness of women,
the empowerment of women because women
are women and now men are beating us at
our own. Gay Men are better at being
women than women are. That's not fair.
And so I do think you see
feminist pushing back on that,
who truly do believe that.
Okay.
The reason why we fought for the
empowerment of women is because women are
unique. Only women can have children.
Only women can do certain things.
Women are better at some things that
men are. As far as leadership goes,
as far as organization goes,
things like that.
And they fought to bring
those things to the forefront.
And now none of those things matter
anymore because you can be a man and be a
woman. So there is just, I'm
just so glad I'm not on the lot.
It just seems so confusing.
It's quite miserable. It is. All right,
so your Prager u video make men masculine
again. Why did they have a man do that?
Why did they have a, what was the
idea? We're going to have a woman. Yes.
Talk about male,
a male masculinity.
I think it's because you're seeing a lot
of women talk about how terrible toxic
masculinity is and say, Oh man, they just,
they don't even know how hard today's
and David Presta us for so long.
We just need them to take a back seat
and so we can kind of step up and do our
thing. And so I think they wanted
the perspective of a woman to say,
hang on just a second. Women actually
do, not only do we like masculine men,
um, or it not even necessarily
traditional masculinity.
I'm not talking about like
riding a four wheeler,
I'm talking about taking responsibility
for your actions and taking care of your
family.
I'm taking care of that provision and
protection that men are so good at it.
And I think better at than women are.
Um, so you could still wear a nice shirt,
let's say. Yes, you should be able
to take care of your family. Yeah.
It's more internal traits
than anything else.
And the actions and the habits that you
have, the responsibilities that you take.
Women do care about that.
And actually the complimentarian
relationship that men
and women have had for
ever, um, has, has worked really
well. It's worked really well.
Not always. I mean, sometimes it goes
over to a patriarchy and that's not good.
I don't think oppression of women is
good, but the, the ying and the Yang,
the back and forth and uh,
the complimentarian relationship
that we've had has worked.
And I think you kind of needed
to hear a woman say that.
So why do you think the
left trying to destroy that?
Because they think a gala Tarion
is and will equal equality.
So it's equality through homogeny,
which is part of why abortion is a
really big thing that they fight for.
If a man can physically walk
away from an unwanted pregnancy,
oh woman should be able
to too. I mean, pregnancy,
the ability to get pregnant is really one,
not one of the only things,
but probably the biggest thing
that makes a woman different.
And so if we get rid of that through
abortion and that maybe men and women
really well be the same and
maybe they really will be equal,
then there'll be no abuse, no oppression,
no patriarchy, things like that.
But I mean men are always going to be
physically stronger than women and there's
always going to be bad men and that women.
So oppression won't stop,
abuse won't stop.
Egalitarianism is just going to make
or not shouldn't say egalitarianism,
but sameness is going to make
things more confusing, not better.
So I know you do a public speaking too,
and when you go to colleges,
do you find you have any
tricks on how to wake up,
say some of the lefties
that are, you know, at least
open to some of these ideas,
but they're kind of like,
oh, she must be the bad guy,
but I'll at least go and
sit in the back of the room.
Well,
what I tried to do is I try to,
my messages typically when I can usually
speaking to mostly conservative is that
okay,
you're hearing that you're crazy for
believing and things like border security
for being prolife,
for being pro capitalism.
But here's where these ideas come
from and here's how they have worked.
And really only over the past 10 to 15
years have we heard all of this crazy
intersectionality,
identity politic stuff that they
are acting like his main stream.
And so you're not the extremist,
you're not the radical,
you're not the one that's out there.
You're not the Nazi and the big that
you believe things that Americans have
believed since our founding.
Yeah.
And they have a really good
history and a really good basis.
And so I don't know if that has
necessarily ever changed a leftist mind,
but it is something that's different than
just talking points and saying the is
stupid. It saying, hey,
we have good ideas and you have a right
to believe they're good ideas and you
have a right to defend these
good ideas. Um, really the,
the most disrespectful or the craziest.
I always get very respectful,
great liberal students that come and
listen and ask awesome questions.
I think the only time that has been like,
oh my gosh,
I can't even get a word out without these
people screaming is when I was at UC
Berkeley and I spoke to yes.
And I spoke to a class and the professor
was awesome for asking me and I
actually thought when I went in
there, I was like, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna be really tame,
really tame with what I say.
I'm not going to say I'm not gonna
throw any flames or anything like that.
Oh my gosh, I couldn't even, it was like
they had never heard a conservative idea.
They'd never heard, uh,
someone who wasn't a liberal,
utter a word and it was irrational.
It was irrational.
That was really my only experience
where I was like, this is crazy.
They've abandoned thought.
Do you in a weird way, blame the baby
boomers for this cause it's their kids,
right? Like, or it's the end of there.
The young end of their children,
like weird way.
You can't blame the,
the 16 year old who now gets into college,
you know, a couple of years go by,
he's been indoctrinated in high school,
gets to college,
gets slammed with more of this
up. I have sympathy for him. Well,
when they're yelling at me, I don't
have that much sympathy for it. Yeah.
But like I have sympathy
for that condition because
they were just thrown into
that. Yeah. Um, we're not that
you're looking to blame somebody,
but if you had to sort of figure out
where this whole thing started. Yeah.
Where would you go?
Well,
the baby boomers
really liked to talk about how terrible
millennials are and I agree with them to
some degree.
I mean a lot of the stereotypes that
people have of us stare entitled and
apathetic or true,
but I remind them like we were raised,
like we were raised by someone,
we weren't raised by wolves and I don't
think it's so much that parents probably
told their kids to be entitled
or told their kids to be spoiled.
I don't know if it was a lack of
values that were taught in the family,
but also there was a significant change
from the time our parents were kids.
Like my mom for example,
was you know she was driving to the
liquor store to get her dad beer when she
was like 13 years old. I mean car seats,
like that just wasn't even a thing.
I mean everything was a lot more
free to the time where we were kids.
I remember there was like a new law that
said you have to be in a car seat until
you're like in second grade or
something like that. Everything changed.
Everything became more safe and everything
shifted from like the latch key kids
who were coming home and
fending for themselves.
That's mostly generation x because both
their parents had jobs to kind of these
helicopter parents and these,
everybody gets a trophy or this,
everybody gets a trophy
mentality that we had in school.
It's not like we didn't have competition,
but it was the,
everyone gets some kind of reward. I
would know. I'm terrible at running.
I'm so slow and yet in every race
I thought I got honorable mention,
honorable mention, I got something and
that's how we were raised. I swear to God.
So I'm, I'm Gen x so I'm a
little yes, but I swear to God,
I remember being in third or
fourth grade field day and I was,
I was a scrawny little kid.
I was not a good athlete.
I became a good athlete later and I
remember getting a slip a field day.
I did not place,
I didn't get a medal and I
remember getting some sort
of participation thing and
I'm not kidding.
I remember as a third or fourth
grader thinking this is nonsense.
Like why would you give me this? I felt
shitty. I felt bad, I sucked it. Whatever.
We were doing like a slow bike race
and I sucked. So why that, yeah,
we've, we've sold this as if
this is how it's supposed to be.
Yeah, I think, I mean it's parenting,
it's technology, its values, its purpose.
It's so much,
I mean you do also,
you can't deny just the effect of
personal technology hat on millennials.
And I mean we had iPhones from
the time that we were probably 15.
We had cell phones.
Even before that we had my space.
Zenga if anyone remembers
that you had a Facebook, oh,
I think it was before my today. I didn't
have it, but I remember some people did.
You had AOL instant messenger.
So you had personalized technology from
a really young age that told us that
everything is about you. Um,
everything is focused on you.
And then the older that we got, we
got Netflix, we've got Uber eats,
we got all of these things that
made life really convenient.
Instant gratification. Always. We
don't know anything other than Amazon.
I don't know how to read a map.
Like I don't,
I remember my dad tried to teach me how
to read a map in high school. I was like,
yeah, dad. Okay.
Do you remember Dennis had to refold
it. Yeah. The rest it's like whatever,
but then you can just fold it
back in the way it came out.
Well, I don't even know how to do that.
So, and I think most millennials don't,
and so this instant gratification things
should be easy for me as they are in
the technological world has
really affected our politics too.
Do you feel that the technological part
of this is actually really screwed up a
generation then like that?
There's obviously a lot of goodness and
we're doing this on youtube. Yeah, yeah.
All of that. But that it really
like we have, we handed everybody,
it didn't matter what age you are.
We all got handed this incredible
technology to open the world, our heads,
but especially if you're a 15 year
old being handed that. Yeah, that's,
that's a lot to give a kid.
Yeah.
I want to hesitate to blame
all of all of it on technology.
I also see a loss of values and that
we're not only the most progressive
generation,
but we're also the most irreligious
generation where the biggest generation of
religious nones in o n e s and I
do think a lot of us are wandering,
looking for truth, not really
knowing what that is. Not me,
but a lot of people in our generation.
I don't know if that comes with
technology at all or if that's connected,
but it certainly a factor in why you
think millennials just don't have any
center.
They don't have any grounding and they
just think that their centers themselves,
they were told this all
the time on social media.
I mean your favorite fitness blog or your
favorite self help author is just love
yourself. If you just look
in the mirror in the morning,
you tell yourself you're awesome,
that you're enough,
then you're going to be fine
and that's what you need to do.
Everything's about my happiness. So you
cut out the toxic people in your life.
You cut out the things
that you don't like,
the things that make you sad and
you just do you be pretty lonely?
Yeah,
I mean there's right and w I mean,
what do you do when
the self love runs out?
What do you do when the
self esteem runs out?
What do you do when you wake up in
the morning and you're like, okay,
I'm not that awesome and I
haven't accomplished that much.
Should you just continue to
coddle yourself or should
you do something about it?
In the millennial is told cuddle,
you'll be flying and then you have
someone like AOC saying, well,
we're going to provide economic security
for people who are unwilling to work.
And so if you just want to
be, uh, a watercolor painter,
even if you suck at it,
you should just keep doing it.
Yeah. So that's where a lot of money
in watercolor paint in general.
I wouldn't know because I'm not
good at it, but, um, I can imagine
gay marriage, let's talk about it. Oh,
okay. From a Christian perspective.
So when we're posting this, uh, we're
holding this video for a couple of days,
but I just had a Shapiro in here and
we've talked about gay marriage and he
talks about his feelings from it
Orthodox Jewish perspective. And we can,
we've basically gotten it to the place
where we agree to disagree and we agree
to disagree on the,
on the fact that he's not okay with
it through a religious perspective,
but he's not trying to legislate my
life and I as a citizen of this country,
I'm completely okay with that. Yeah, I
suspect that's probably similar to yours.
It is similar now as a Christian,
there is a little bit of,
um,
I would say a second layer to that.
So he obviously believes
that homosexuality is wrong
because the old testament
says it. We believe it, not
just because the old testament,
but it's reiterated in the New Testament.
And then there is this crazy picture
in metaphor that is given to us in
Ephesians five that says,
okay,
marriage is a reflection of
what Christians call Christ
in the Church as Christ
is the head of the church.
So the husband is the head of the wife.
And so it's this,
um,
husbands are to love their wives as
Christ loves the church and wives are
supposed to submit to their
husbands as to the Lord.
So there's this spiritual component,
this gospel component to marriage
being between a man and a woman.
So there really is no theological
way for any Christian. They try,
but to get out of the
dynamic that God set up,
not just biologically and physically,
but also spiritually.
And so that's where I stand as
far as religious perspective.
Now I've heard both sides of it.
I have heard conservatives and even
libertarians that I respect saying,
you know what, I, I
just can't get behind a,
I just can't get behind gay marriage
from even a civics perspective or from a
legal perspective.
You heard Libertarians make that argument?
I've heard it. I've heard liberty.
I would say not anyone famous.
I would say friends who probably have
libertarian views still saying maybe that
was,
maybe they don't feel that way anymore.
But just say it's so hard for me to
separate the personal from the political,
but where I stand politically
is probably the same.
I would say probably the same
place as been dies. I mean,
one gay marriage is here to stay.
There's nothing that's going to be
done about it. And I don't think I,
or probably any other evangelical in
the political world is going to fight
against it.
But I think
what does that tell you quickly
about the delicacies in general?
Because I think this is important.
I've, I've said this many times,
but it's like nobody cares
about gay marriage anymore
really in the big picture.
Like I get your, your theological,
yeah. Personal belief,
but in the public political space,
yeah.
Something that was an Athema to this
group of people for a long time now has
become normalized pretty quickly I think.
I think by and large,
Christians have realized that their
communities are, and getting worse,
that the neighbors next door have kids
and they're the same as everybody else.
That you don't even hear Mike Huckabee
going on about it anymore. Or, or, um, uh,
Rick Santorum or any of these guys,
they've sort of moved on.
And I think this is where I would love
the progressive's have a little humility.
Yeah. Like just a little bit of, you know
what me, maybe you guys were wrong, right?
You were wrong, but then something
happened and you did you let it go? Yeah.
Basically.
And that would show a little humanity
and humility and they just refused to do
that. And again, this is
where then I can find myself,
be building bridges with you
guys all the time because, yeah.
Because there's a place
to build a bridge to.
Yeah.
I think that a lot of evangelical
conservatives realized,
okay,
yes,
America was founded on Christian values
and we should continue to perpetuate
those Christian values.
But the state does not define marriage.
God defines marriage. And I think that,
uh, churches it be free to say, sorry,
we're not gonna, we're not gonna marry
two men. You know? And I agree. Right.
And Yeah, and I knew that you did. Um,
and I think that we kind of made that
separation and it say and said, okay,
God defines marriage in the Bible.
If I don't want to get on board with
it because I am beholden to God and God
above the state,
then that's fine in churches shouldn't
be beholden to the state in that regard
either. And I think that we kind
of decided, okay, that's fine.
If they want to get married according
to the state's definition of marriage,
that's okay.
But I and my congregation are not going
to change our views on it and we just
kind of want to be left
alone in that regard.
Yeah. So what would you,
what do you make of when,
when churches do perform
gay marriages? Like, yeah,
just sort of skirting their
theological, yeah. The,
or integrity.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
this is a huge thing in the United
Methodist church is that they've kind of
almost had a split because they voted on
this so called traditional plan saying,
okay,
if you're a Methodist church,
if you're under the United Methodist
Church umbrella, this denomination,
you can't perform gay marriage or
you can't. Yeah. You can't perform,
you can perform these marriages.
And there were a lot of people who
are really upset about that. And,
but from a Christian perspective,
you just can't get around it.
There's no way to get,
there's no way theologically to get
around it without making some serious,
not just physical concessions,
but spiritual concessions.
And so my question for anyone,
and it's not just about gay marriage,
it's about anything in the Bible.
My question is,
if you don't take the Bible
as God tells us to take it,
why are you a Christian? Find a different
hobby. Like there's that you can,
you know, you can be a
moral person. You can, yeah,
you can be a good person and you can
believe in feeding the poor without
following Christ.
But Christ tells us to deny yourself,
take up our cross and follow him.
And part of that is adhering to the
word even when it's inconvenient and not
culturally cool.
So I'm just a little bit confused
by those theological concessions.
Um, but yes, to answer your question,
I do think that it's compromising
on what the Bible says.
Yeah. What do you think that would
actually in practice, what does that mean?
You know what I mean?
Like, so in practice,
gay people start getting married now
doesn't matter. Outside of the church,
what do you think the practice of that
would lead to in society? That would be
all right. Are you talking about
Oh, okay. Outside of the church.
So like I understood. Yeah.
Outside of the church.
Did you see that some sort of problem?
Well, I, I, I of course do you think
that God's way is better than Nan's way?
And I do believe that God's setting up
marriage as a union between a man and a
woman is better. I think
that it's better for, uh,
I think it's better for the family.
I think it's better for children.
And I think because it's better for the
family, it's better for society now.
Do I think it's going to be
the degradation of society?
Do I think that we're,
our whole thing is going to hell in a hand
basket because of that? Uh, no I don't.
But of course,
I think that the way God set up marriage
and family and the Bible is better than
how secular society does it.
Um,
and so that's where I feel that,
I feel like we are,
I feel like we'll probably be going.
However,
homosexuality isn't different or are
necessarily worse than other sense.
It's a different kind of sin because it's
a sexual sin according to Christianity,
but it's not worse.
We don't believe that it puts us in a
worse place than all of the other sense
that American.
Yeah.
Dot. Well, I know what's
going to happen now,
so people are going to clip this and
they're, they're going to go out. See,
there's Reuben sitting with another
homophobe right to his face sitting in his
house where he lived. You like hanging
out with homophones. It's just like,
I don't, I mean, I said it to
Ben, so I'll say it to you like,
as long as you're not trying to
legislate my life, I don't care. Yeah.
Maybe there's a part of me that I'm like,
maybe I should care more.
Should I be more offended?
Or something like that.
Don't, well, I think
part of it too is one,
you want to be left alone like so many
people like Christians due to go live
your life. Yeah, you want to be
left alone. And I think also,
and you can correct me if I'm wrong,
but a lot of the problem that especially
Christians see on the left is that they
conflate sexuality with identity.
And so if I disagree with your
relationship from a Christian perspective,
um, then that must mean that I
hate you, but I don't hate you.
I think that you're a great person.
I think you're a smart person and
your husband's awesome. And so they,
a lot of people on the left seem to not
be able to separate those two things.
That I can love you as a person and
respect you and admire you as a person and
not agree from my own Christian
perspective with your relationship.
Now I also think it's important
to say though, it's not.
If I were to what Christians
would say witness to you,
if I were to share the gospel with you,
it would not be, hey Dave, you're gay.
And that's wrong. That would not be the
message. What we believe that unbelievers,
people who are not Christians are
repenting from when they come to Christ is
unbelief.
It is not your primarily your primary
San is that you're gay or that you are a
thief or that's your anything else.
It's that you don't believe in Christ.
And so that's what we believe,
that we are preaching the Gospel to
unbelievers to be saved, not a gay people,
to make them straight. Now we do
believe that through sanctification, uh,
that we all have to repent
from our sense. But, uh,
I think it's important
also to distinguish that,
that what we're talking about salvation
and sharing the gospel with people.
It's not necessarily saying,
uh,
our primary message isn't that
you're gay and that's bad.
Yeah.
What do you think people could just stop
being gay if they repented and stuff?
Well,
I know two different stories.
There is a really good book by someone
who I totally disagree with and so many
ways in so many ways, but, uh, she,
she wrote a good book. Now,
she probably wouldn't say that,
oh God makes people straight, but
it's called gay girl. Good God.
It's by Jackie Hill Perry.
And she did live life as a gay person
and then she kind of had an awakening.
She came to God and she's married and she
has kids. There are stories like that,
but I also know stories of people.
Um,
there is another amazing story and I
don't want to say the title because I'm a,
I don't want to say the title,
but there is another story of,
of someone who became a Christian.
He lived life as a gay person.
He actually was in prison,
um,
and he lived life as a gay person and
he at became a Christian and he lives,
as far as I know,
he loves to sell a bit lifestyle.
And so he is not married.
He is probably never going to be married.
He might not ever be attracted to women,
but because he is a Christian and Jesus
has called us to deny ourselves whatever
our desires are that are simple,
uh, he loves the celibate lifestyle.
And so I think
this strikes me as deeply sad.
Like I can get it. Yeah. You know,
like I really like, you know, I'm
pretty tolerant about this stuff.
Obviously that one just strikes
me as he, he is gay. He,
there is this religious
piece of him in there that,
so the answer is then live alone and
don't have kids and don't have a family.
Yeah.
But that is where you start completing
sexuality with identity and romantic
relationships with the
ultimate fulfillment.
And that's not what the Christian
beliefs actually Paul says for everyone,
it's better to be single than
to be married. Um, he says,
I wish you were all like I was.
So you can be fully dedicated to the Lord
and we believe that if you're straight
or gay straight or you're
same sex attracted,
then the gift of celibacy is truly a
gift that you can dedicate all of your
passions to God. Um, so we
don't see celibacy as this sad,
awful lonely thing. We believe that
in Christ you have full fulfillment,
full satisfaction, whether
you are attracted to the
opposite sex or the same sex.
And so I think he would tell
you, great person had on,
I'll tell you his name, but,
uh,
I would think he would tell you that he
finds full satisfaction and full of joy
and his relationship with Christ.
Now that does not mean it's easy.
Right?
Well,
I was gonna say he would also sort of
have to say that to rationalize his
existence, right? Like
may I, I don't know. I'd be
happy to have the conversation.
I'm not sure that he would,
I don't think he would have chosen
because he was living and actively gay
lifestyle. His name's Christopher.
You won. And I think he's incredible.
I don't think he would have chosen to
be a Christian or I don't think he would
have become a Christian. Um, if he didn't
think that there was something to it,
if he didn't think that it was worth it.
I mean,
he's seeing the two alternatives
and he chose one direction.
So he obviously thinks that one is
more satisfying than the other. I mean,
he got nothing out of, at least hand
to bully in this life saying, okay,
I'm going to give that up.
And become a Christian.
Yeah.
So it makes you wonder,
it does make you wonder.
It should make you wonder
about Christianity.
What is it about Jesus that would make
someone give up what they thought their
identity was? Where the world
says, well, that's where love is,
is just being yourself and loving who
you want to love. What kind of God,
what is their degree.